how will we know the end
[Music]
no no
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thorns season 8
and Game Theory's video I wanted to do
another Q&A video that way I could
discuss some things that you have been
thinking about I did receive a ton of
great questions this time so I think I
will make another video next week that
way I can't answer some of the ones that
I didn't get to today like all my other
Q&A videos I try to answer the questions
that have the most likes because I
assume those are the ones everyone is
wanting to hear me talk about the most
so what that being said let's begin the
first question is from Tendo Payne and
it says I have always believed that the
knight King has his reasons for what he
is doing and that he is not pure evil he
might even be the 13th Lord Commander of
the Nights Watch and the songs about him
are lies certain tales about the others
are lies george RR martin did say many
times that the villain is the hero of
the other side what are you expecting
regarding the White Walkers in the night
King to be revealed first I just want to
say I think you're absolutely right
the night King is not pure evil or at
least I don't think it was this man's
desire to be killing everyone you could
kind of see by the way the night King
was created he didn't ask for this the
children on the forest had to tie him up
and gag him so they could turn him into
their instrument of death and
destruction he was created for one
reason and one reason only the children
were at war and they needed help in
order to save their own race and their
sacred trees if they never would have
created him this wouldn't have happened
but in their mind it was their only
option and it obviously worked at least
for a time there has to be some reason
to explain why the night king eventually
turned on his own creators something had
to happen that caused them to start
killing again but we have seen a few
instances that prove they aren't purely
evil because they have spared some lives
in the very first episode they allowed
one of the Rangers from the Nights Watch
to live and in the next season they
allowed Samwell Tarly to live so if
their only goal was to kill every human
they would have killed them too I think
the most logical explanation for why the
others are back and killing again is
because some pact or agreement must have
been broken
no one knows exactly how the first long
night ended the legend about the last
hero says the others were advancing and
on the verge of defeating the humans
until the last hero and his twelve
companions set out to find the children
of the forest the twelve companions
ended up dying but the last hero did
find the children of the forest and
shortly after that the fighting stopped
and the long night ended it never said
what actually happened though we don't
know how the last hero when the children
were able to get the others to stop and
go back north the others obviously
weren't completely defeated or else they
would all be gone but we know that isn't
true because they are back so to me it
makes sense that the last hero and the
children of the forest and the others
must have came to some kind of agreement
and whatever those terms were must have
been broken the others stayed away for
thousands of years so whatever happened
had to have been fairly recent I don't
think it was the birth of the Dragons
either because dragons were around
hundreds of years ago and the others
didn't attack anyone so it has to be
something else and I think it will be
the last big twist the showrunners and
george RR martin bose said there would
be three big twists in the game of
Thrones series according to them
princess Shireen getting burned alive
was one of them inho doors reveal and
death was another one so that only
leaves one twist left and I think since
we haven't learned why the night king is
back it must have something to do with
that I think we will learn what is
motivating them and it's probably going
to come as a surprise to most of us but
I don't think it's because their
intentions are purely evil George said
that all of his characters and creations
would be gray so it wouldn't make much
sense if they were just mindless killing
machines that's not what he wanted to
create the next question is from gaudy
to 14d town and this one says how
important is Arya Stark to the final
endgame you're not gonna like my answer
but I have to be honest I don't think
she is very important in terms of the
endgame I don't think Arya will be the
one to kill the night king nor do I
think she will be the one to kill Cersei
Lannister however I do believe Arya will
be very useful she has had some
excellent training over the years and
she now
a Valyrian steel weapon I have already
went on record a few times saying I
think Aria will kill at least one white
Walker with her dagger but she might
even kill more than one it just depends
how many White Walkers are left
also with Arya's ability to wear
different faces she could be used to
slip behind enemy lines without raising
any suspicions but I don't think they
need Arya to win any of the wars even
with her training she's still only one
person and unfortunately for her
character she's not one of the extremely
special characters like a Daenerys who
has dragons or John who is the Song of
Ice and Fire
now I should say if arya decided to
settle down and get married and have
children she would be very important
then especially for House Stark because
their name is on the verge of going
extinct there are only a few Starks left
and none of them have any children right
now but someone from this family needs
to produce an heir and it should have
the stark name which ever remaining
Stark decides to do this will ultimately
save their house that's one thing Arya
could do that would raise her importance
up a couple levels but Arya doesn't seem
to be interested in that let's just hope
one of them will before it's too late
the next question is from I'm mote and
it says what about songs are ending up
with Podrick after what she's been
through she could use his magic
cockadoodledoo well this kind of relates
to what I was just saying about Arya
Stark it would be nice to see one of the
stark children start a relationship that
way we could have some kind of hope for
the future John is about to have a child
but he doesn't carry the stark name
since he is the king I guess he could
technically give the kid whatever name
he wanted but I'm not so sure that he
will I have a feeling we will see at
least one of the stark daughters enter
some kind of a relationship before it
ends but I doubt so and so we'll end up
with Podrick
it just doesn't make that much sense to
me Podrick doesn't come from a very
powerful house and him and Sansa haven't
even really acknowledged each other so
then getting together what kind of come
out of nowhere
if Sansa ends up with anyone I think it
will be Terry an organ jury this story
is mostly based around the War of the
Roses and that was ended when both
feuding houses entered a marriage
since the Starks represent the york's
and the lannisters represent the
Lancaster's I could see Sansa in Tyrion
getting back together in the end in
order to stop the war between these two
families I also think Gendry would make
sense to Gendry will most likely be
legitimized by John or Dany that way his
house doesn't go extinct either and we
know ever since season one that a stark
and Baratheon marriage was on the
horizon Robert always wanted to join
houses with Ned since they basically
grew up as brothers and this could be
done with ginjury marrying one of the
stark daughters this next question is
from neo B and he says in season two
Theon Greyjoy said that Ned Stark said
one hundred men can defend Winterfell
against 10,000 men do you think this
will come into play in season eight yes
this will absolutely come into play and
we have already seen evidence of this
thanks to some of the set photos
Winterfell welcome under attack and it
will even be burned but I don't think
the castle will fall this castle is very
magical it was built by Brandon the
Builder with the help of the children of
the forest most of what we see was built
much later but its foundation sits on
top of the crypts of Winterfell and as
long as there is always a stark here the
castle will remain it might be severely
damaged by the night Kings Dragon but it
will not crumble like the wall did at
least I hope not if a hundred men can
protect this castle against ten thousand
and I think a thousand men should be
able to protect it from a hundred
thousand whites but we know Winterfell
will be guarded by much more than that
almost all of the remaining north men
will be there plus the unsullied into
three key and whoever Jaime Lannister
possibly brings they will also have two
dragons against one so I am pretty
confident they will hold their ground
the next question is from Game of
Thrones addict what role will the
direwolves play in the upcoming season
ghost is obviously very important you're
right the direwolves are very important
even though they are highly underused if
it wasn't for these dire wolves some of
the Starks would have died a lot sooner
some are saved bran on more than one
occasion and some are saved Jon as well
even though it was mostly brand
because he warmed into him but you know
what I mean these dire wolves were a
gift from the old gods and the starch
were meant to have them at their sides
at all times almost as if they were
their shadows it's very disappointing
that they can't be included more but I
understand why they are left out of the
bigger battles a direwolf what it lasts
very long when you have mountain men
charging at you not to mention all the
arrows that are typically being loosed
but I am hoping ghost has a bigger role
in the final season I'm not so sure
about Nymeria in her pack though it
almost seemed like aria and Nymeria said
goodbye for the last time however that
doesn't mean I'm Iria and her pack won't
show up again I know a lot of people
have been wondering if they will show up
and save Aria at some point next season
and I actually made a video about a year
ago and in that video I talked about
brain Stark's superpowers I thought it
would be really cool if brain was able
to ward Nymeria into our entire pack and
bring them north I don't know how likely
that is but I believe we could see one
of the Starks gets saved by a direwolf
again since there is only one season
left why not go out with a bang and just
include every single thing that you can
they have a record-breaking budget again
so there is no reason why we shouldn't
see ghosts or even I marry a play some
kind of a role I should warn you though
don't hold your breath let's just hope
the writers of the show have heard all
the criticism for not including ghosts
in season seven the next question is
from D ranks and it says other than John
Daenerys and bran which character do you
think will be the biggest x-factor in
defeating the night king and his army in
my opinion it has to be Melisandre I
think she has always been the x-factor
in terms of meeting the night king her
only problem is no one wants her around
because her approach is a little hard to
grasp for most people but they will need
her and she is coming back to Westeros
to provide that help the last time
Melisandre talked to Jon she made it
very clear that he needed her you've
seen the night King Jon Snow you know
the Great War still to come you know the
army of the Dead will be upon us soon
and you know I can help you win them
whoa Melisandre is lifework has been
trying to find a Zora hi for when the
time
to face the darkness she has always
known this day would come and she has
always known she had a role to play this
has always been a story about two
opposing sides coming together which is
ice and fire the night king is the
ultimate symbol of ice not only is he
made out of ice but he can manipulate it
with his magic but then you have
Daenerys on the other side who
represents fire because of our Targaryen
blood and her dragons but you also have
Melisandre who knows how to manipulate
fire what their magic you could also say
that Melisandre has already played a
massive role in defeating the night King
because she brought ice and fire
together and they will lead the fight
against the others
the next question is from wahlid and it
says do you think the night king will
talk no I doubt we will ever see him
talk and according to the writers we
never will they were asked this question
during an interview and they basically
said what would the night King say
anything he would say would be
anti-climactic
they said it would only diminish his
character so after reading that I don't
think it will happen the next question
is from giannis and it says do you think
that there is a possibility for Abbess
Ariane to be killed by a Valyrian steel
arrow used by the ballista yeah I think
that would work we have seen Valyrian
steel and dragonglass killed the night
Kings creations before so I don't see
why it wouldn't work for the dragon -
Mara killed a white Walker with a dragon
glass tip so a Valyrian steel arrow
being shot out of a ballista should
certainly do the trick
I think a weirwood arrow could work as
well as long as it could pierce its skin
unless it hits its eye then it should
definitely kill it I also think drug
gone might play a role in vissarion's
death as well since Dragon was named
after Khal Drogo and Viserion was named
after Viserys we might see another Drogo
kill another Viserys if you would like
to hear all of my thoughts on this topic
then you should definitely check out my
video called how to defeat the night
kings dragon in that video I listed all
the different ways I think Viserion can
die but just answer your question I
would say yes a Valyrian steel arrow
shot out of a ballista should kill him
this next question is from Abu Ali and
it says do you think Cersei Lannister is
truly pregnant or is she just faking a
pregnant
see to make Jaime Lannister stay with
her and fight by her side yeah I
actually think she is pregnant although
I wouldn't put it past Cersei to do
something like that
we know Cersei will go to any lengths to
hold on to her power but I think she is
telling the truth also the entire plot
leaked last season and it was 99.9%
correct the only scene they left out was
Circe's miscarriage and Varys speaking
to the little birds if her pregnancy was
faked I think it would have been noted
in the plot league somewhere and even
though she never had the miscarriage
I still believe she will I think it
might even be used as a plot device to
help push Circe's madness even further
this unborn child is the last thing she
is holding on to but once she loses that
all bets are off she will go out in a
blaze of glory I'm sure and she will try
and take everyone to hell with her I
will answer one more question in this
video then I'll get out of here but I'm
saving all the other questions you left
because there were so many good ones I
didn't want them to go to waste so I'll
make another video out of those sometime
next week this last question is from
lucid horizon and I felt like I should
answer this question soon because I have
seen this become very popular as of
lately
this one says have you seen the
Littlefinger faked his death theory and
if so what do you make of it yes I have
seen this theory because everyone was
asking me what I thought about it so I
did go and watch the video and first I
just have to say I thought it was a
great video
it was very well put together and the
evidence that was provided was very
intriguing and I also think it would be
a cool twist on Littlefinger's death
however I do not think it's true
Littlefinger is dead and he won't be
coming back but I do want to say that I
did not like how Littlefinger story
ended last season he obviously deserved
to die but the way it led up to that was
very underwhelming in my opinion I think
that storyline in Winterfell last season
was atrocious so I completely understand
why some people don't want to believe
that's a little finger died I would
prefer if Littlefinger had one last ace
up his sleeve but I just don't think we
have enough time to do that all of the
focus needs to be on the night King and
dealing with Cersei Lannister but let me
know what you think I talked about
several different things in this video
so feel free to leave several different
comments if you have some opinions about
some of the theories I discussed today I
want to thank everyone for watching this
video I really do appreciate that and I
also want to thank everyone on patreon
that supports this channel have a great
day everyone I'll see you soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]